bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission les
petits bricoleurs aujourd'hui je veux
montrer comment réaliser un hélicoptère
comme celui là à partir de récup haut
pour cela nous avons besoin d'un rouleau
de papier de toilette d'une chute de
cartons de la peinture on les choisit de
couleurs de la colle pinceaux crayons
papier d'un cutter d'une paire de
ciseaux de tournevis ou d'un objet
pointu d'une attache parisienne et d'une
règle alors donc on va passer au
découpage des différentes pièces pour
monter l'hélicoptère pour fabriquer
l'hélicoptère donc on va commencer par
faire un cercle
copé le cas du rouleau de papier de
toilette ensuite on va faire la partie
de l'arrière de l'hélicoptère
donc ça une forme comme une cuillère
donc on va comme ça ensuite on aura
besoin de l'hélice donc sa foi me dit le
croit
ensuite on aura besoin d'un cercle un
peu plus petit que le premier
poursuivre nous aurons besoin aussi des
petits rectangles comme ça quatre petits
rectangles pouvons nous servir du patin
et rectangle un peu plus petit voilà
donc on a tous les éléments pour
construire l'hélicoptère donc maintenant
il suffit de les découper
alors pour la découpe on utilise le
cutter
non
vous
maintenant on va passer au montage donc
on va nous rendre un grand certes on va
le mettre
on va coller là donc on met de la colle
tout autour et donc on va venir boucher
voler c'est shane kippel ensuite va
prendre le tournevis ou un objet pointu
on va faire un petit trou pour pouvoir
mettre les lys évidemment pour les
droits de l'ange alors dont vous avez
aussi un petit roë les lis qu'on va
perfo qu'on va faire un trou juste de au
milieu au milieu de l'hélice le petit
rosé juste dans le milieu on va faire un
coup on va mettre la tâche parisienne
donc apprendre la tâche parisienne pour
le glisser dans les dix dans le petit
rôle dans sa lettre le moyeu d'une
retour donc on va le mettre là
des insectes donc on va l'ouvrir la
tâche parisien voilà voilà donc ça va
donner ça alors dans un deuxième temps
on va faire une feinte sous la cabine on
va dire pour cela nous avons besoin d'un
cutter alors donc à faire une petite
fente comme ça il faut faire
délicatement parce que c'est fragile
alors il faut faire pensions pas se
blesser aussi pour vous prendre un petit
carton rectangle qu'on va le glisser
ensuite on va prendre les deux
rectangles on va coller comme ça non
mais un petit peu de colle sur le bord
et on met les patins donc là on laisse
sécher un petit peu donc on va prendre
la partie arrière là on va faire une
fente à ce niveau là et vous allez
prendre le petit rectangle que vous
aller glisser à l'intérieur
voilà ça va donner un facteur
stabilisateur
ensuite vous avez un tout petit
rectangle
on va faire une petite fente au milieu
je vais mettre un petit point de colle
là que je vais lycée là
voilà et donc voilà ce que ça donne
une fois montés l'hélicoptère maintenant
il ne reste plus qu'à à décorer qu'à
peindre
alors moi j'ai choisi le vert et le
jaune
on va commencer par là
le court terme
alors voilà l'hélicoptère convient de
réaliser ensemble et moi j'ai fabriqué
aussi un autre avec de papier décopatch
mais vous chez vous pouvez me faire avec
ce que vous voulez ce que vous avez à la
maison voilà les missions étant terminée
et moi je vous dis à bientôt à une
prochaine